foreign
[Music]
welcome to the Next Generation data
analytics with bigquery and palm
I'm Chris Crosby I'm a group product
manager here at uh bigquery and I'm
focused on Advanced analytics Advanced
analytics is a set of capabilities that
we have within bigquery that go beyond
just SQL this is things like adding
spark stored procedures
um going after adjacent market like log
analytics and search but then also
things like Ai and mL of course join
with me as soon as you want to give a
quick intro hey everybody I'm Shane Metz
I'm the CTO at Faraday and uh yeah we're
a consumer predictions uh company but
you'll hear about more about us later
yeah thanks so a quick rundown of what
we're going to talk about today is
um we're going to give an introduction
to Google's data and AI cloud and I'm
going to give a demonstration of our
interface for that now which is bigquery
Studio we're then going to hit on some
of the foundational models that we've
actually integrated with bigquery I'm
going to show a very lightweight rag
demo with bigquery data and then finally
uh him back off the Faraday he'll talk
about how they've put some of these
capabilities into their customer
analytics platform
so ml is pretty pervasive throughout all
of the Google cloud data tools there's
obviously vertex which is this whole
Suite of machine learning tools but then
bigquery has integration for doing
machine learning at scale our
operational data warehouse databases
like alloy and spanner they can use the
inference endpoints that you would
create in vertex and you can have looker
that gives us predictions back to the
business
but what we had found by working with
customers is the journey for creating
these Ai and ml applications you're
going to go across a lot of these
products that each have their own
interfaces that you might end up
switching programming languages
sometimes you're even trying to move
data in and out of these different
systems and that's why we announced this
week bigquery Studio our goal with
bigquery Studio is we want to give you
that guided path through the data and AI
Journey uh if we want to make it easy to
tap into all the different various
languages and as we started to build out
bigquery studio and its interface one
thing that we realize very quickly is it
wasn't just a UI problem either we
needed a more natural programming
interface for bigquery other than just
copying the SQL statement into a python
notebook and so as part of bigquery
Studio
we've also created a new uh python
package bigquery data frames
this python package it pushes to Ai and
ml processing that's done typically it's
done locally in your notebook that's
going to go back into bigquery and then
that's going to let you work with these
Cloud scale data sets that you really
need to build generative AI applications
now the Big Frame package that's going
to come pre-installed in bigquery studio
Enterprise co-lab our notebook Partners
hex and deep note but you can also just
go and pip install this right now and
try it out
this big frame package it does have two
different apis one is
bigframes.pandis uh it it's not exactly
pandas but it should be very familiar
for those of you that uh are coming from
a pandas background and it is for data
exploration so the things you're going
to be able to do in here is things like
input output of data if you need to
bring in data from different uh Source
systems and put that into bigquery it
makes it easy to do that there's
um
manipulation including things like
indexes and sorting
it gets you access back into the python
ecosystem so it lets you tap into
different visualizations you might be
familiar with like matplotlib and
Seaborn and finally it lets you write
your own custom Python and then deploy
that back into bigquery and run your
python code on bigquery data at scale
the second API bigquery.ml
this is essentially bqml exposed as a
python interface so all the bqml
function that's built into bigquery is
also here but very soon there will also
be a handoff to the vertex 2.0 API so if
you did have a custom model you'll be
able to hand that directly to vertex 2.0
and it'll understand how to work with
that uh Big bigquery Data through that
big frame
so now that we have python exposed in
bigquery I thought it'd be fun to get
started with bigquery studio and find
some useful python packages maybe you
might want to go try out here
so what you're looking at here is just
our landing page for bigquery Studio
which is probably going to look familiar
to a lot of you and what I'm doing here
is I'm searching for a table that might
have some python functions and I'll go
ahead and preview this data
and what comes back here is a bunch of
information about the python packages
that are available in Pi Pi looks kind
of interesting so I'm going to go check
out the landing Edge it does look like
folks are using this and I can go and
look at the exact SQL statement that
generated that table and I'll Trace that
back to the initial tables where this
came from and I can see very uh easily
that this through the lineage does this
really this came from a bigquery public
data set this is just data that we have
in bigquery that we expose to you to
make it uh easy to get started with a
lot of common data sets and so I now can
go look in our Marketplace check out
what that data is
and I see that it's got this uh uh all
the details about this how where it came
from and now I kind of know where that
data came from I trust that table so I'm
going to go ahead and start to look at
some of the descriptive statistics that
are associated with this and very
quickly I can feed things like you know
there's about 4 800 is the average
download of python data most of the data
in here is going with python3 so it
looks pretty interesting so what I'd
like to do now is explore that further
with the python notebook and so I'm
going to come in
and we'll turn it uh we'll spin up a new
light dot notebook
by default I'm going to have two
different ways to get started with that
data the first example is traditional
pandas if you think your data can fit in
memory the second one shows you how to
get started with big frames the
background connections these are all
vertex runtimes the same ones that
you'll use with Enterprise co-lab and if
you're using big frames for the most
part you can stick with the smallest
instant instant size because all the
processing is again getting pushed back
into bigquery not the notebook
so just a very quick you know getting
started with pandas here here where I
read in the data into a big frame again
it is happening on the bigquery side you
can actually see the uh at any point the
job that's actually getting generated as
a SQL statement behind the scenes for
this so there's a quick example in this
instance here when I'm creating the data
and it stays in bigquery I can even give
it unique indexes so if I know that I
have a primary key in my table I can let
the I can let G read the read gbq know
what that is and we'll use that we'll
keep all the data in place and you can
see okay here's the data uh just running
a simple head that came back information
about the python functions
and here I can this is just another
piece of typical painters manipulation
I'm doing a filter I'm looking for the
Big Frame packages that are out on Pi Pi
and you can see that there's actually
I'm trying to figure out the number of
downloads what are the popular downloads
and there's a lot of roads for big
frames because every time I went and
changed a description or a version it
created a new row
so I'm just going to do a simple Group
by via a pandas operation and now I have
essentially an index of names with the
number of data logs next to it
and again
um
well I'm just now turning that into a
data frame and what I want to do though
is I'd actually prefer that this data be
sorted by the number of rows instead of
by the name and so I can reset the index
this is something you don't typically
get in a data warehouse where you have
to go you don't have guaranteed ordering
but we can create this within the data
frame within the Big Frame and so I can
see them it used to be the name that's
the index name but now I want to
actually store these sorted index by the
number of downloads you can we also do
support multi-indexing if you need to go
through multiple layers like you would
in typical pandas that's available but
what I can do have now is a sorted index
for all of the Python packages uh to buy
number of downloads and then let me just
take a quick look at you know what are
maybe not the most popular packages
those are pretty familiar to all python
users but like what are the next set
between like 20 and 50 that might be
interesting for us to go take a look at
and so that's what comes back
now of course this is all just a
precursor this is how you typically
would get started with your machine
learning just exploring the data
understanding what's there
there is a lot of text here also
associated with this data and so I'll
show just a quick summary
but then we're going to come back to
this later and do some more interesting
things with the actual text description
so just a a little teaser here
um
now you may have noticed something that
was happening on the left hand side as
this whole demo is happening is there
was versions of the notebook that were
getting stored as we were doing all
these manipulations
so I'm gonna actually go and look and
compare the notebook that I was playing
with versus the original notebook that I
started with and you can see where all
the changes occurred and so I'm going to
go ahead and just go ahead and revert
back to the original notebook that I had
and restore that version
and so now back you know right where I'm
starting from I had that whole version
history as we went
and now that I have this notebook and I
have some cool packages maybe I want to
go share that with one of my teammates
so I'm going to go ahead
here this notebook with Joe Malone our
notebook product manager
yeah Joe uh
and so we share that with Joe we'll just
go ahead and make him an admin so he can
go and clean up all of my code and fix
that for me
and now it's shared with him and I can
go save that notebook and uh move on and
so that's generally bigquery uh studio
in a nutshell and how you could use that
to get started with some of uh your data
analysis
now I want to get into some of the
Innovations we've actually done with the
vertex AI foundational models in
bigquery so we've extended the bigquery
SQL capabilities with llms there's now a
remote SQL function that you can use to
run a SQL query and that's going to use
the vertex text bison model on your
bigquery data today text bison is backed
by Google's Palm 2 large language model
but over time you can expect that those
underlying models are going to continue
to evolve so you're always going to have
access to Google's latest Innovations in
the AI space
what did I when I said you know
integrating with SQL what does that
actually mean this is a good example of
what it means what you're going to do is
you're going to come in and create a
remote model that references a cloud AI
large language model V1 again that's
Palm today and then I can now run a SQL
function that can generate text I give
it the model name and then I give it a
prompt along with any data that I might
have that uses it this example here I'm
generating some new data where I have a
bunch of cities in a column and I'm
saying hey give me the country for these
cities and it'll generate new data that
might be useful for Downstream analysis
I can't go forward
okay
I think this is
yeah so here's the next demo very
quickly to show off how we're actually
using this and this is a real example of
something that we did on the big frames
team in this example I'm going to use
the big frames.ml API so we use pandas
before now we're going to use the ml
package and you can see what comes back
these are mostly a subset of the bqml
models by the time we hit General
availability all the bqml models should
be there and I'm just going to set this
up and what I want to actually do here
is I want to use the Palm 2 model to go
and help us bug batch big frames to help
us find some examples that we didn't
quite get right the first time and we
want to go fix that and so what I'm
doing now is I'm reading in a CSV file
that contains all of the apis for
um for a pandas data frame
and I can go do a quick check and look
for
the API and when I read that in csvn it
actually does move it into bigquery and
it keeps all of the you know the rows as
you would expect all the ordering and so
what you're seeing now is just all of
the different API calls that are
associated with the pandas data frame
now what I want to do is I want to set
up my prompt and what I'm going to ask
the llm to give me is I'm going to tell
it to generate pandas sample code for
data frame and then I'm going to list
each of those apis that were in that CSV
file
so at that point I'm going to run this
prediction this is feed up this is sped
up a little bit for the video
there you go
and when that comes back I'll show a
quick example of what comes back which
is essentially a set of example code for
uh in pandas
for each of the API calls
foreign
gets cut off but those are you know full
examples but they're all in Panda such a
thing and we need to uh test big frames
so python is typically pretty good at
processing so very quick just text
processing function I have right here
I'm going to tag it as a remote function
when I do that what happens under the
hood is that's going to get deployed to
Cloud functions and then it's going to
create a remote function in bigquery
that hooks into it
and so all that's Auto deployed so you
can actually run that python code at
scale I can see the names of either one
of those functions that were created I
can give it a name so if I wanted to
hand that off to somebody else or know
what that name is or keep that in a data
set I I could do that but in here we
just created a default data set a
default name but you can go see I search
for it and it does exist as a SQL
function as well in bigquery so I can
come in and you can see what this
function does it's pretty simple but
what it does is from bigquery SQL I can
just put in import pandasource PD and it
returns import big frames SPD that's a
SQL statement that's running python
under the covers that you could use as
any other SQL statement
so back into our notebook
I now I'm just going to apply this is a
you know standard data frame technique
of applying that function to our
original llm code and now I have a bunch
of big frames generated code from the
llm that we actually did go and run
against big frames to go find a bunch of
bugs to we could go troubleshoot
so what are some use cases you might
have for ML generate text uh we are
working with a beauty supply products
company and they're creating
um personalized emails so they have data
in their database of columns that are
like demographic information like this
is a woman from uh canvas who's age 60
and then it's personalizing the message
that they want to send to them
it's really good for a lot of common NLP
tasks that can get problematic so those
things like classification inventory
extraction sentiment analysis llms
really can help simplify a lot of that
and then rewriting and rephrasing so
putting um
we were working with this one call
center and they have a lot of
transcribed data that comes from their
calls it often doesn't the computer
often doesn't get it right it's kind of
sloppy and so they're actually using the
llm to clean up a lot of that data to
make it easier to read Downstream by the
analyst
so
um now that we've talked a little about
how to just call the llms from SQL and
use that with big frames I do want to
give a quick example of how to take the
uh
uh the bigquery data warehouse data and
use that to actually put some guard
rails around that llm
and I'm going to do that with a vector
search using and now generate text
embedding and ml distance so before I
hop in here just to show you before I
hop into the demo just to show you what
we're going to get so you have an idea
of what we're doing is the step first
step is we're going to train this Mantic
embeddings which is we're going to take
that python data and we're going to
transform it into numerical vectors and
then we're going to go find within the
uh the vector space similar clusters of
information
so
let's pop into the demo
so the first thing I'm going to do here
is we're just going to create one of
those remote models this is essentially
the same thing that you saw in big
frames but this is going to be just the
SQL version of it
and I'm going to create a prompt it's a
table of props that's just one prompt
which is what's a good python package
for working with embeddings in bigquery
and then I'm going to go ahead and call
out to the Palm model and I'm going to
get back the answer to that question
using that model and my prompt some good
packages for working with embeddings
and you'll see what I get back here and
I can set something things like the
temperature
what I get back is BQ embeddings it's a
good choice for working with embeddings
and bigquery it provides simple
intuitive API blah blah blah that sounds
awesome I definitely want to check out
BQ embeddings I'm going to go use BQ
embeddings right now so let me go take
BQ embeddings and do a search for that
in that list of python packages that we
have from pipei
and it turns out there's no data because
there is no package called VQ embedded
just completely made up it's just a
hallucination by the llm it's nonsense
what do I do so what we're going to do
here now is I'm going to take the actual
data about the python packages and I'm
going to create vectors out of for each
of those based on the palm embedding
model here now we do support other types
of smaller models if you need those like
uh Bert and some of the other ones but
here I am using the llm one
and now just so you can see what it
looks like after I run that function in
bigquery is I have on the left hand side
this is an array of numerics along with
some other information including the
original content that uh I I want to
list from the table
so with that I'm not going to create a
stored procedure so just a script that's
runs in bigquery and what it's going to
do is it's going to augment that prompt
as it come in as it comes in the input
is we're now going to be the The Prompt
that I send it and the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm just going to take
the query that comes in and I'm going to
turn that into a vector itself and what
that's going to allow me to do is I can
now search within the vector space
against the that python data against the
query that I give it and see what are
the common things that are clustered
around it are you going to use ml
distance ml distance is a Brute Force
technique so you're going to get the
slowest result but probably the most
accurate result most of the functions
within bqml doof does now support
embeddings based on that what comes out
of the content generation but we're
going to use these ml distance here and
I'm going to limit to the top five
packages that come back and then what I
do here is I'm going to just Loop to the
top packages and I'm going to extend my
prompt to understand what these packages
are and that way I have some guard rails
for the L1 to say Hey you know provide
me the answer but within the the scope
of the data that actually exists and
makes sense you have some data to feed
in and so now I'm gonna then the last
step is I just rerun that exact same
file model I did before but with my
augmented prompt so I will now kick off
that stored procedure in a separate call
here
so back into SQL games just a SQL
statement but you can see the steps as
it runs I'm going to rerun that exact
same uh prompt which is what's a good
python package for
uh working with embeddings in bigquery
and now we kicked it off and you can see
the you know we're now going to actually
do
um
do that distance function to find
similar real data first
and that's what this is a show that's
what that is right there and then you
can see the prompt the new prompt that
gets generated and so this is now the
new prompt that gets generated which is
from the below list of python packages
provide the answer to the question then
it's the input that I had and then a
list of real data uh from the warehouse
and so with that new prompt I have a new
answer to the question about what's a
good python package for working with
embeddington VQ
and that answer is
the best package we're working with uh
bigquery is Big frames and that's legit
big frames actually does have a bunch of
embeddings it's the right package you
should go use if you want to try to do
this
so what are some use cases for Vector
search
um that you just saw it's oftentimes
good for long-term memory so it's kind
of expensive and processing heavy to
create a bunch of these uh vectors so
you want to keep them just stored in
bigquery that way if you have other
algorithms that you want to do again you
don't have to regenerate the embeddings
uh semantic search it's a very very big
building block for semantic search
especially you can pair it up with
things like k-means model which we also
support and have some blog post around
um as well as just things like
recommendations find me similar things
that's uh step one of what everything
you saw just now because exist today you
can go use it coming very soon and we
are looking for you know preview
customers for this uh by the end of this
year we are going to also support Vector
indexes directly within bigquery meaning
that you'll actually have a
um a way to quickly that you can just
point a uh using SQL you can just Define
a vector index on a table to point to
the embeddings and we will keep those
updated in an index behind the scenes
that's going to provide
um approximate nearest neighbors search
two other real quick things just the end
on of ways we've integrated llms into
bigquery one is document analysis a real
quick highlight on this one
um if you put your data through document
Ai and you have a bot a lot of
structured data on the bigquery side we
can actually generate a table of all of
the information completely structured as
a table on unstructured data with this
functionality and then finally our
bigquery migration service which is a uh
it's basically a compiler with a bunch
of heuristics for converting different
languages like teradata SQL into
bigquery SQL we've now augmented that
with additional AI recommendations so if
you don't like what's coming out of the
compiler or there's something missing
you can just generate an AI
recommendation then accept the reject
that
so with that I'm now going to hand off
to Saturday to talk more about how
they've actually used some of this stuff
awesome hey everybody so I'm Sheamus I'm
uh I'm the CTO and the co-founder of
Faraday and I've heard us described as
headless AI or machine learning for
Commerce and we're built on bigquery the
the number of things that you know Chris
just showed is just scratching the
surface of all of the functions that are
revealed directly in
um in the data warehouse and so
when a new function comes out in
bigquery ml we're often able to turn
that into a new product on our platform
so let me see if I can
here we go yeah we power the predictions
behind a lot of call centers tablet apps
uh vertical crms basically if you have a
database of us consumers then we can
build lead scores churn scores uh all
sorts of all sorts of different things
and what sets us apart is that we're
using
um
third-party offline data responsibly
sourced to enhance that so instead of
just looking a customer in terms of the
number of times they've come to your
website or some Anonymous device
details Faraday actually knows every us
adult and can work from features like do
you like to Garden do you like cats
what's your household income all that
stuff and something's not mentioned here
but there were were happy to announce
this quarter is uh the ability in our
models to mitigate bias along any one of
our demographic features and so you know
let's say you're in you know banking or
fine banking or insurance and you have
requirements around
ensuring that you're not doing proxy
discrimination well you can actually
actively invert bias inside a machine
learning models so we're trying to
follow Google's responsible AI practices
and and build that all and make it kind
of table Stakes for any buddy trying to
do consumer predictions
so we also do LTV and all of these
things correspond to
um
essentially functions made available to
us in bigquery now it's funny when Chris
said you know create a remote model for
the llm you know create a remote
function the thing about bigquery and
bigquery ml for us is that it's not
remote right it's all happening inside
of our data warehouse and so we're not
doing any ETL and we've
um
we've used all the different model types
up here on the screen everything from XG
boost to k-means to build Real World
products and a story I like to tell is
before bigquery ml our data science team
would develop a new product a new a new
approach and then they'd pass it off to
the platform team and the platform team
would turn it into HTTP calls and retry
logic and all that stuff but ever since
we moved on to bigquery ml our data
scientists are building the models
themselves by invoking SQL from python
so
sometimes it's a lot to process when we
look at you know bigquery Studio which
is an amazing Innovation but you kind of
ask yourself well could I really build a
real world application on top of a
studio product no and that's not the
point you know it's more for
experimentation when it really comes
down to building uh
a machine learning product in this day
and age
you're probably going to be using python
to do the orchestration to to kind of
set up the stage but the ability to just
invoke SQL and take all the knowledge
that your employees have about SQL which
has been around since the 70s uh instead
of having to relearn window functions
and pandas and all that stuff and again
Big Frame is a great product my data
scientists have been asking for lazy
data frames for for big query for a long
time SQL is really a great way to do
this stuff so explain predict that's a
good example of the SQL function built
into bigquery that lets us create
explainable AI so that when we do a
prediction of propensity to purchase
across 50 million customers we're able
to explain on every single row why that
person got that score well it's because
they like cats or it's because uh you
know they live in this area or something
like that so it's it's very feature
complete that's another thing I'd like
to say about bigquery and vertex in
general is that the variety of model
types is
um is very strong and so you know I
think one of the most popular use cases
is time series but you've also got
classification regression clustering and
all of it works at scale and so when
when Faraday was transitioning from our
previous provider to bigquery ml one of
the things we're able to do is basically
take tables that were 250 million rows
and 250 columns and run predict against
it with a brand of forest with 256 trees
in it and it just you know it took 10
minutes and the key thing was that it
always worked you know we didn't have to
to build a lot of orchestration around
that
so one interesting use case for
generative in particular is sentiment
analysis and that's because when a
client comes to us they have structured
data in the form of transactions click
stream view stream but they might also
have call center logs or you know other
notes that their employees have taken or
somehow collected and so
if we can extract this then we can use
it in our predictive models right we can
essentially create features
uh from unstructured data and so here's
a real example of a call center log
and then what we did was we tried to
first use the cloud NLP function so I
hope there are product managers in the
room
and what we found is that it just didn't
get it like when we tried to ask it well
how does this person feel about
financial products
the NLP API just didn't quite get it
right it wasn't making connections uh
holistically
but then
you know we asked the llm we did the
create remote connection uh to a text
bison model and then we ran this
um
but we ran this prompt
and we started immediately getting clean
uh you know a clean analysis of it now
one interesting thing about this is
um
sometimes the llm would respond with
here's your answer and then a markdown
block full with Json and then sometimes
it would respond back with just plain
Json and so among other things you can
um
you can tweak the parameters to ml
generate text and turn the temperature
down to zero to get a really serious
answer instead of a really creative
answer so that's a good a good tip there
also
um I if I understand correctly if you're
trying to
if you want an explanation to be
returned in a certain form that would be
a good use case for fine tuning and
fine-tuning in in uh in bigquery ml's
llms is related to fine-tuning and
vertex Ai and it basically resolves down
to make a a file where every line is
adjacent with an input and an output and
then the llm kind of learns how you want
it to respond to certain things and
there's other projects like Jason former
that we've been talking to the product
team about maybe implementing but anyway
this is this is really cool because if
I'm building a model for retention or
lead scoring or anything like that for
this financial client
I can get a sense of how people feel
when they when they've called in so this
is something that
um is really cool and nice to have right
next to the data
another use case is content generation
and I was very happy to see this I was
at a chat yesterday with the chief data
officer of uh and I'm going to mangle
this pronunciation of Carrefour which is
the biggest retailer in France and
possibly in Europe and
um
he had a chart of projects that could be
done with generative and he had one
access was impact and the other axis was
feasibility and so
the most impactful and the least
feasible at least according to his
initial analysis was something like a
Content Factory that would allow you to
generate personalized marketing and so
what they did was
turn briefs into very targeted marketing
campaigns so what we're going to talk
about a faraday though is since we have
access to individual consumers that a
business has
and we also have a national data set of
demographic data demographic property
Financial life event all that stuff
we can actually personalize the messages
on a per person basis
um
so you know today and this goes back to
the whole advantage of bigquery ml being
that all this stuff is built directly
into the database instead of having to
be accessed through the network you know
the previous approach was you know let's
spin up a a very robust HTTP call to
some external llm which by the way you
know you also have to be concerned about
ensuring that whatever prompts that you
send in are going to get saved on their
llm which is another advantage of the
vertex AI Foundation models is you own
that particular model and anything that
uh that it sees is is going to stay in
inside of your VPC so the previous
approach was again the network but with
llms and bigquery we can create a prompt
from every single row of data and so
here what I'm doing is I'm saying I'm
joining my marketing campaign which has
one Roper person with my demographic
data which has one row per person in the
whole United States and I just picked a
couple different attributes to tell the
model about and so what I loved about
this was that I took a real customer of
ours that sells intelligent humidifiers
and I said well how would you rewrite
this for an older person and it
immediately came back and I don't know
maybe they should fix this in their
marketing in general but it's it you
know it's it simplified it down to a
humidifier that turns itself on and off
now
content generation is fraught and so one
of the reasons we picked product
descriptions instead of an entire
marketing email to start was that we can
imagine rolling this out where
um
you know maybe it's under the fold it's
the kind of thing that once you've hit
the initial marketing message that was
written by a human
maybe we follow up with some gen AI
generated uh customized content but uh
some of the
um I was actually talking yesterday with
the CTO of the world's largest marketing
agency
um who some of you may have seen a
keynote and he was saying well take a
rag approach you know uh or maybe what
Thomas was talking about you know with
in grounding and just ensure that
um you're able to
ensure that the llm is making responses
from a real Source about your particular
product another another time I tried
this and this was actually before I
turned the temperature to zero I asked
it to to come up with some marketing
text for another product and it invented
a tech not like a humidifier technology
that didn't even exist it's called like
clear air or something like that so you
do have to be a little bit careful with
that
on this use case I will also say an
interesting
um an interesting possibility to think
about is using
the results of predictive AI like
decision trees to inform your prompts
right so like if I'm gonna do this for
all of my customers I don't just want to
always have the marketing message be
generated according to age and gender
right depending on product affinities
there might be different things that
affect
who that Brand's clients are and so
again using bigquery ml classifier
models I can build a model predicting
who's likely to be a customer in the
United States and then I can look at
those feature importances and say well
maybe I'll take the top five you know
maybe one of the top five is like an
interest in science and then I can add
into my prompt you know
rewrite this message for somebody who
has an interest in science so it's still
early days uh but it's it's a very
interesting and and and chiefly it's
something that you can experiment with
without moving this data anywhere
without you know asking your data
scientists to write any python to take a
CSV and hit an open API or you know some
kind of an API
so that was our two use cases and if it
if it comes down to one thing it's the
integration I I think that the lack of
the fact that you don't have to ETL
stuff the fact that Google research is
essentially taking care of parallelizing
everything it really
um I think is a an interesting approach
that you should consider when you're
building a machine learning application
is instead of going towards
you know python pandas spark it's it's
interesting to to build it just directly
in SQL uh because you know it's kind of
the lingua Franca
[Music]